this is the forbes ai50 list
50 of the most promising privately held
ai companies in the united states
we created the af50 list four years ago
to educate and inform the public about
ai
we're in the early innings of the ai era
all the ingredients needed for ai are
increasingly abundant there's more data
than ever there are more computer
scientists working on ai algorithms than
ever and there's more computational
power than ever and every year i look
forward to putting together our ai 50
list
looking at 50 of the most interesting
and promising private companies in the
us and canada that are using artificial
intelligence to create a range of new
businesses and services or help overhaul
traditional industries work to make them
operate more efficiently
the selection process this year was a
tough one we had more than 400 completed
applications
and we had a dozen judges working with
us this year
with ai expertise including professors
and executives with established
companies that are leaders in the field
of artificial intelligence most ai today
falls under a field of computer science
called machine learning
machine learning allows computers to
make predictions using historical data
for example
most weather predictions are an example
of machine learning
historical data is used to predict
future weather
all the companies on this year's list
either use or enable machine learning
most of machine learning is based on
statistics in particular bayesian
statistics which is a field of math that
uses historical data or beliefs to make
predictions about the future because of
this ai generally requires three things
data to learn from software to do the
learning which we call algorithms
and computers to run that software
there's a lot of activity in ai in every
industry it's a huge growth area and
every year
the number of companies vying for
inclusion on the list seems to increase
in terms of trends that we're seeing a
noticeable one
would be a continuing growth in the use
of ai
in biomedical research pharmaceutical
research medical testing
those particular fields
undoubtedly this is related to
the impact of the pandemic
and the need to find new types of
treatments for different illnesses but
there's also a lot of ongoing work
to go after cancer and other chronic
diseases
using ai to try to accelerate testing of
potential drugs and treatments that
could be very valuable for the future
[Music]
in other areas
autonomous vehicle technology is always
a regular feature of the ai list there
are great many
av companies that apply every year but
an interesting trend would be a shift
away from
more traditional types of autonomous
vehicle companies that are developing
the technology for robo taxis and
personal vehicles and a shift towards
companies that are readying
their ai software for trucking delivery
logistics
and in that area
a standout company that we saw this year
would be wabi
a startup that came out of stealth in
2021 led by raquel erdison a computer
scientist at the university of toronto
raquel also previously was a member of
uber's autonomous vehicle team
and she was a former judge for the ai 50
list in 2021
we have other really interesting
companies like farmwise that are using
ai and robotics to help farmers remove
weeds from their fields without having
to use chemicals they have designed and
are beginning to
roll out a
new generation of robotic farming
equipment that do exactly this weeding
of fields
companies like aurora solar in san
francisco which uses ai machine learning
to custom design solar power systems for
residential and commercial buildings a
very useful
application of the technology that can
rapidly design a system which is
important in a state like california in
particular where we're trying to quickly
shift to as much renewable energy as
possible
ai is
really being felt in every industry
across the board
and sometimes in ways that people don't
immediately notice it
part of why it is such an exciting time
for ai is that there are more of all
three than ever before
first let's talk about data the world is
producing more data than ever it's hard
to say just how much data there is out
there but experts predict that the
amount of data created captured and
consumed globally will be around 100
zetabytes in 2022. that's about 100
billion gigabytes and over 15 times as
much as a decade ago
that means for ai there's way more data
to learn from than ever
second let's talk about algorithms
algorithms are generally written by
computer scientists who focus on
artificial intelligence
algorithms get better each year because
of these scientists
ai is now the number one concentration
amongst computer science phds nationally
three times as popular as the second
highest concentration
because of this the future of ai
algorithms looks bright
finally let's talk about computational
power this one is particularly hard to
measure because there are a lot of new
ways of measuring processing power
however one heuristic to measure
processing power is moore's law a
decades-old prediction that the number
of transistors on a chip will double
every two years that's a 32 fold
increase in a decade this translates to
faster computation than ever before
and new chips designed for ai are even
faster and better than moore's law might
suggest the interesting thing also that
we're seeing is
greater diversity in founders and ceos
at ai companies across the board
certainly more women
are founding and running ai companies
and people from different backgrounds
that we hadn't seen traditionally
are beginning to get funding and get
started and
get their ideas out there undoubtedly
we're going to continue to see
artificial intelligence
applied to literally every industry and
it may just be something like monitoring
processes in a factory to make sure that
worker safety is not at risk or that
processes are being followed in the most
efficient manner because of the ever
increasing amount of data ever improving
algorithms and ever growing computer
power ai just keeps getting better and
better